on this week's show should property
investors do the miracle morning in the
news half of property investors would
not touch by to late at the minute why
is that and we're gonna be answering all
your property related questions welcome
to the property investors podcast thanks
so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
hyoma solids I'm Alistair Cunningham
hound welcomes the property investors
podcast we've gone for a little bit of a
different theme today yeah I love it
one of the one of the questions that we
get asked a lot is what books do you
recommend should you read element books
so always hard to do is just try let's
see what you guys think what we're
thinking of doing once a month a book of
the month encourage people to read a
book every month read along with us what
we're reading and you know you can give
us your feedback will tell you our take
on on it so that's kind of what playing
on do is it should be pretty pretty good
shirts good before we get stuck into it
have you been good I'm really good just
getting moved in getting settled in the
apartment so it's it's getting there
turns out the property was fully
furnished but the front shows a bit [ __ ]
go on why it's just all wonky and wobbly
so I've had to ask them to remove it and
I'm have to get a lot of new furniture
did it go wobbly after you sat in it no
no it's just like the table the coffee
table like you live in it it's like
where is this
I have condor in the same thing yeah
this furnished as well no but there's
kind of two lounges so I decided to do
well the the lounge that the living room
air my furniture didn't fill it right
the room is like 35 foot by 20 foot it's
just like massive how the other half
live II yeah and my foot I was like it
was I was torn I was like do I try and
match it that this is the place I bought
myself from doesn't sound like that's so
for anymore so I can't match it up
it's
so I decided to do is move that into the
other lounge and then just redo the
entire lounge did you go out and find
all the stuff or did you get like an
interior designer to do for you I just
bought the stuff myself
oh cool Simon was using the interior
designer whose name was yeah yes yeah
yeah no I didn't I squat I may be it may
be a pseudonym but I quite enjoy it I
can't enjoy peak picking out so yeah
that's a problem yeah that's actually
why color coordination I think it was
your thing was not your thing is that
you colorblind oh yeah I'm actually I
have that much red one that's green
actually yes I was good man we're all
moving in this this move to London's
been a lot more expensive than we
thought
but I'm loving it's a big investment I
love it as well I'm loving it loving it
right okay cool yes anyone watching this
you should move to London come to London
the grass is greener on the other side
anyway
in this case well there's not much grass
but it's the grass that is here is green
with our offices right by Regents Park
and that's very yeah actually the nice
isn't there right okay so but
book-of-the-month yeah you're reading
one I'm hearing lots of good things
about it I am I've had lots of the lots
of people mention this book in a
password that when you talk about it on
the Russell actually wronged me up when
I was on an uber on the way into the
office today
like all like super excited about
there's books in out so you've got to do
this and then he named the title and I'm
like I've been hearing about this book
for a month well this book has been on
my on my sort of reading list for for a
couple of years actually okay but I
always I'm always adding to it and I've
always pushed it down the pile and part
of the reason was was because I didn't
it's called miracle morning expired I
called Hal Elrod so part of the reason I
push it down on this is because um I
don't particularly love the mornings so
me I I normally get about half by 6 to
my daughter coming in the room and then
it's sort of like bobbing her off yeah
for about half an hour and then I get
about seven it's kinda like a slow
process to get ready for work go to work
it's kind of my days it's not exciting
more I don't do anything I just get
ready I think I think and then come to
work and then and then what I am good at
is I listen to audio books while I'm
driving or now we're in London and the
community I'm commuting meeting him so
that's kind of what I do in the morning
I sort of thought I don't we have time
for anything in the morning because I've
kids I'm calling everybody for work or
leave early
I do a lot stuff during the day I'm kind
of okay but at the same time I'd always
fancied having some sort of routine so I
am a big believer in routines
booyah and I've never managed to get
into a lot of the stuff I do reading
exercise right it's more ad hoc rather
than that rather than that rather than
routinely so I'd always thought to put
it off anyway started reading it and the
first thing that he talks about god it's
great great book you know or inaudible
I'm listening to it yeah so it's very
interesting he's been through a lot a
lot of stuff eatery back so he got brain
damage and all sorts of stuff and the
the miracle morning is what he used to
sort of turn his life around when he was
going through depression and problems
and stuff like that and it is it is
brilliant it's basically to my personal
development right and he talked about
the six the six things that he
encouraged you to do every day and set
as a habit in personal development and
they call some his save us
SAV ers so the six things are silence
yep it's Golding FS mmm affirmations
mmm-hmm visualization mmm-hmm
II exercise yep reading no not reading
se ve are was our last my subscribing so
just remember what they are I do they
have me do them every day
silence affirmation affirmations
visualization excess exercise oh yeah is
reading sorry reading and scribing which
is writing but
think of anything that began with a
diplomat with an ascot Matt yes that's
it that's that's the sails there there's
and what he says is do ten minutes of
each my every day so takes you an hour
okay and if you do that every day it
will make a big difference job so some
other do anyway so I'll read anyway yeah
I do caught in silence meditation I do
that but not every day I maybe do four
times a week maybe so I thought okay
I'll give it a try and he recommends
doing a 30-day challenge where you did
where you do it for 30 days and if you
like it you can reading it forever yeah
it becomes habit unto you if you do it
and it becomes part of your day as
opposed to oh I've got to do that mmm so
one of the things we've done with it
with the staff is we've made them do ten
minutes off now Australian sales
training yeah between every single day
and they do that before they come to
work and I believe they're loving it I
believe they're loving it was only
little exercises they have to do every
morning to his little disciplines that
make a big difference is now so I'm
loving it I'm in the first couple of
days he talks about how like for to make
a habit you traditionally to make a
habit yes they recommend that sort of 21
days or I've found for me I use like the
acronym fate for me anytime I'm starting
a new habit so F it's fun the first
couple of times you do it it's fun you
excited about it yeah then it's awful
yeah so it's like almost agony yeah I
can awful agony unbearable almost
terrible and that lasts about 10 days
just terrible then it's just terrible
it starts off for it turns into agony
all that it goes terrible and then it
eventually becomes enjoyable okay so
they're the sort of stages of it so
right now I'm on terrible at the time I
love it the rest of time when the alarm
goes off because I'm doing it from half
five til half six I don't want to do it
before my daughter gets up she was only
on for about twenty five plus five so
when the alarm goes off I am
and the other thing is a mime and a
bride come doing everyday Monday to
Monday to Sunday so even on some now I'm
getting about half past five
yeah I mean I don't sleep that much
anyway so like I'm always a week at that
time anyway so it's our five five five
six I'm always awake so don't sleep that
much
I sleep probably four hours a night if
that yeah and what they look at is what
it's excuses so number one sort of
excuses are you know I need I need to
sleep and they do research in to sleep
and how much sleep you actually need do
you know that does my head in when I
hear people say that when people tell me
they need 12 to 14 hours a day sleep and
like sleep quicker honest water Snickers
as well so many people I was serious
there's so many people like when I heard
I'll tell you what and so many people I
hear they want to come on to do properly
the crash course the Academy events
things and they say they haven't got the
time to do it the Academy for instance
and I said well like what do you do for
a living and we start talking about it
and the and they're allocating like 12
hours to sleeping and make sleep quicker
I was watching a society says sleep
faster sleep faster you don't need that
which is easily he's five those five
hours he sleeps five hours five hours a
day how about you me five to five to six
hours max so I not remember last time I
slept more than six hours I thought I
can't remember last time I slept more
three hours were waking up Wow see I
need more than that no I feel like I
need about seven well what I find
happens is I'll sleep for like I would
to bed at midnight one o'clock and I'll
be up by six o'clock our week by six
o'clock and then what happened every
couple of weeks I'll like crash during
the day for like four or five hours I
would just I'll get I'll get very tired
and a little bit yeah I'll get overtired
and the devil sleep didn't do ever
already just slightly longer every day
might just stop that you're back and I
can't get my body to sleep more really
that's the thing I wake up and I'm a
week and even if I try to go back
sleeper can see I used to be like that
yeah but I used not I slept more than
that but if I woke I if I woke up in the
night I'm not like it's 3:00 a.m.
right now yeah it's got so many thoughts
to go for your mind because you always
think in we're all with what we're doing
the business we're always thinking about
what's next how can we make this better
how can we do that I've got myself out
of there now
have you heard you do that I had kids
okay
well that helped he just got me out of
it because it was like well I'm I
couldn't live like a wake up there
crying wake up just maybe now that we've
moved all the big stuff that was
happening in our lives and we walk and
that's happened
so maybe no things are gonna start on
good it's been my so I'm so I'm like I'm
about seven hours so I'm in Tibet about
half ten yes about half ten go to bed
eighty seven hours isn't it having about
seven hours which is enough yeah and
what I'm thinking is what he said a lot
of it your mindset so when you wake if
it isn't for me if I have to get up at
half past five yeah normally are below
half five painful I'll be expecting to
be like tired in the morning but because
I'm expecting to be tired I am yeah
whereas now when I get a bear don't look
at the time I look at how much sleep I'm
gonna have so I get a bit of half ten I
think wow I'm gonna get seven hours of
nice sleep and I'm thinking I'm focusing
on the seven hours yeah on the half five
so yeah seven hours is perfectly enough
sleep for me I'm gonna be fine when I
get about wake up's get straight up
brush your teeth straight away minty
freshness
yeah that'll water because you're a bit
dehydrated yeah and then bang straighten
I do find it helps like if you set an
alarm as soon as that long because off
get out of bed yeah don't like snoozer
and snooze it just you're on goes off
get out a bit doing the meditation
straight away I do and then go straight
I've changed the order a little bit I
preferred the order my way so the
meditation first straightaway then go
into the visualization these are such
powerful stuff man then go into the
affirmations yeah so I'll switch those
two around because I find I'm better at
the visualizations straight from
meditation so I'm in this state yeah
then reading yeah and then after that do
the scribing and I finished the exercise
could have a shower so yeah and I'm
doing like an insanity workout so I'm
ten days in so I'm using very long no
not on me 1111 days in so tomorrow with
the 12th and I'm really enjoying it I'm
really really enjoying it it's given me
such a good kickstart rather than mean
rush movie morning yeah I've got time
yeah to just relax and be and do do you
know without having the kids there and
everything before that and I think what
it means is all the time I finished up
because I'm doing it's so early
I then spend some quality time with the
kids before I go to work okay which
means I don't feel like I have to rush
back afterwards to go and see them yeah
because I've spent half an hour to
around with them in the moon have
breakfast together I mean I used to get
brothers on the way to work yeah your
sister so it's giving me that nice bit
of family took a couple of hours in the
morning and then I could focus on
working I'm at work I've done now I've
got it out of the way and I'm still
reading on the way to work and lack and
stuff but for the mini Big Mac we should
all read it for next month I would
encourage you guys to video and give the
30-day challenge ago yeah it is hard but
the thing is is when something's hard I
love it when someone's heart because I
know that most people won't do it yeah
and it gives me an edge
yeah gives you the edge so I was easy
everyone would do yeah it's hard but
it's enjoyable
I'm already enjoying it it's already fun
for me so I highly highly recommend it
now some for me there's some tweaks I
would do I would do some things a little
bit differently and maybe at some point
we'll you know we'll come up with our
own sort of it yeah we need to come
version because I'll I just didn't
before I go to bed as well yes but I but
this is brilliant
I highly recommend it no good morning
who's it by Hal Elrod oh cool yeah and I
highly recommend doing and taking up the
30 day challenge he's giving it a lot it
made it he just made it simple and you
know I think that's good awesome
good very good probably recommend give
it a read it's now time for this
[Music]
so in the news this week we are
discussing how half of current property
investors would not touch by tules they
would want to leave the market if they
could and I think that's that's like
quite important and why that is so it's
an IND it's a it's a news article in the
property industry I website and
basically says half of current landlords
would not go near the buyer tulip market
market if they could know if you choose
to know so half of current landlords
would not enter the battling market for
the first time now rather than invest
they would stay out of the market citing
government interventions regulation
changes economic uncertainty and lack of
returns so of the 738 landlords asked
for their opinion over forty percent
said they would only forty percent said
they would still invest in the vital
eight markets that was sixty percent
said they wouldn't touch it with a barge
pole one in four said they intended to
increase the range of the course of the
next 12 months to cover the two to cover
the the increases in costs like packs
things that well the majority of
landlords believe there are rents now at
least one of the properties below the
actual rental value they could achieve
so it's interesting it's interesting
what's your take one on getting into
bags later at the minute it's it's
talked about a lot of the minute and a
lot of yeah various places unlike it is
it depends how you rented out doesn't it
if you're gonna rent it out I mean we
talked last week about you know through
a company or and a lot of these
landlords probably owned them in in
their own name it's just gonna see their
problems about all these tax changes
coming in they're probably just renting
them out for the for the general rent
yeah and they're probably not maximizing
rents through HMOs through service
accommodation through what at whatever
it is do you think it's a case of a lot
of these em landlords are sort of stuck
in their old ways though the old-school
landlords they bought conventionally the
problem repayment mortgages they
probably borrowed through a high street
lengths are not a proper mortgage or
more competitive mortgage Belinda and
now they're in a situation where they'll
probably losing money they're not
getting creative to maximize the rents
will not get in super in so we only get
in general rents well here's the thing
and the doesn't work for the times on
the economy no we were
bruggman the academy called the business
of property investing right and and
basically the idea of that is to take
you from an amateur mindset yeah and
take you to a professional mindset and
the thing is is that 95% of landlords
are amateurs yes their stuff and they're
just they're just like there are then
accidental landlord or they've they've
just gone let's buy that house there buy
a house based on their feelings and and
they're not pros so for an amateur
landlord yeah the rules have changed but
for me this is good news yeah because if
half of that I was trying to get out
it's opportunity for the professionals
to come in and make all make all the
money and yeah I think it's burnt I said
this last week and one landlord is 23
properties he's selling them all great
great lease option for example tax you
want some of the sandwiches yes
anyone watching this that no that
watches our show regularly and knows
about the strategies knows how to do it
tax wise he knows how to buy correctly
knows how to rent it out to make super
Reds knows how to buy it low and rent it
high if anyone that knows all that then
what you want is good oh yeah it's good
you know yes it might drop with brexit
the value might drop but like we always
say it's Nardi it's gonna go back up
again
yeah it dropped in the recession in 2008
it's gone back up and that was a massive
recession and the thing is is that you
know a lot of the smart investors the
professionals they make money
join the ups they make money drawing the
downs so for me I'm not worried at all
its interest and the this that you can't
teach an old dog new tricks I think you
can I think all dogs can learn new
tricks well yeah but it is it's a good
case in point for getting educated yeah
education is key how we meet why do I
really not lean on why did why drug arm
programs what I'm going to prove I was
in a program last week I'm going to
program in two weeks time because I'm
continued trying to educate to learn
more about stuff I don't know so perhaps
a lot of these landlords are stuck in
their old ways I've just ran into the
family then the
for a basic 450 500 amount the basic
general rent where do you think are a
little bit educated and start learn how
to do super rents then that's better for
them surely and they would be have a
thriving business and but the problem
you find is a lot of these older
landlords are so stuck in their ways
that they do not want to change and they
think that everything that comes along
now like the the service accommodation
mode all the things are they all just
think it's dodgy and it's illegal and
risky well what's more risky running
your property a loss or running your
property a profit maybe these Lando's
need to start treating it like a
business instead of treating it like a
hobby or a side hustle and I get so
infuriated with some of these so-called
experts online there are old school
landlords and they make out there so
bloody good at it but they're not
they're old school they need to get
educated they need to open their eyes a
little bit and realize that things move
with the times like move with the times
if you want to keep up you've got to
keep up with the times
what was good ten years ago is not good
today
do you know I mean so move at the time I
mean whatever it's you know it's it's
it's moving everything's moving I'm
flowing so fast you gotta you've got to
keep it with it so sorry Nick there you
go that's all they think of that move of
the times it's now time for this okay so
it's now time for the question and
answer session and so we've taken the
questions from last week's YouTube
videos and also the property investors
with some of these Facebook live it were
done earlier on today and so we have a
question here from miss flea 87 on the
YouTube channel and it says I must say
is it a good question it is a good
question well I'm a single mom full-time
single mom and these podcasts have
helped me gay thank you it helped me
give me the car we appreciate it
to go part-time and focus more on profit
ochres more like it's not actually a
question I will be at the crash course
Umbro woman's opinion it says good to
see you there fearfully we have another
question from 10d and I tend I love the
show
sometimes hours - where's Russell who
knows roughly cutting off Alison when
he's trying to drop some golden nuggets
I know doesn't happen so I said I keep
cutting you off
Pam that's what they're trying to say he
said to meet you for the question
studies ah I'm gonna start talking just
keep cutting me off keep talking over to
me that was why I wasn't it was to make
that point should we get over it okay
okay so this is a question from so your
d alum hi guys we saw your day alam so
saw your day so yo day so yo D so you
pronounced that right man if not and I
don't know if not already okay hey guys
would you advise buying a property to
let out just for recession or afterwards
always looking forward to future videos
I would way if you think there's a
recession comin and price what generally
happens after a recession expansion yeah
house prices initially initially they're
gonna go pop if there's if there's a
recession coming if everyone says there
was a recession coming which and maybe
there is maybe there isn't right but if
there is one comment initially if prices
are going to drop Huntly so that's when
I would be buying when the recession
happens yeah when prices at the bomb
then go up and end up gonna be expansion
if you if you have that confidence there
is recession around the corner I would
wait to the recession hits prices drop
by then wait for the expansion I would
just buy now yeah just buy now and then
there's no salmon's keep buying it and
then after the recession keep buying
just always Bart it's bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye
cool okay another question from if if us
I Foss he's great with their names names
it won't be his real name what mortgage
repayment or homes do you guys recommend
capital and interest or interest only
interest only to build cash flows he's
looking for cash flow interests on the
hundred percent here's a good one here's
a good one
Brian Johnson and so why don't you buy
your own home alistair you rent in
london a property investor rent and am i
missing something
ah good question so they in a nutshell
what he's trying to get out is as
property investors why do we rent as
opposed to Warren
I'm pretty sure amounts of this before
we have but maybe you can fly away with
that one oh okay I'll look for the next
questions let me just go through the
maths as to why I'm gonna use this to
write on okay and you can even work
along this with BAE yes we'll do the
maths right here so they need a
calculator how much my house that I'm
renting yeah is worth one point six
million is that yeah cool so what if I
bought that how much deposit would have
to put down to do the math right now
we'll work out what's better four
hundred thousand pounds
four hundred thousand that's working on
a twenty five percent mortgage so I've
put down four hundred thousand pounds
and how much would my monthly repayments
be on let's say interest only hold on so
1.2 million times naught point naught 3
divided by twelve three thousand pound a
month three thousand pound a month on
interest on on interest only but really
that's working at three percent three
percent which is not gonna be three
percentage each I'm gonna buy for real
company okay so it's me four percent
four thousand four thousand animals
right so it's four thousand pound a
month and it's four hundred thousand
pound upfront and that's very much
interesting so I'm not buying the house
for that there's just the interest right
now my rent on that house is
coincidentally four thousand pound a
month okay right so it's the same so I'm
living in it for the same price as if I
was buying it but that's just interest
so people go oh the rents wasted money
was not waste of money because it's the
same as been just the interest but
rather than putting the four hundred
thousand pound into that house I can put
it into other properties that will give
me a massive cash flow yeah because four
hundred thousand pound will go quite a
long way listen to write which will more
than cover so my house isn't costing me
anything because the money I'm putting
down my properties are paying for my
house
so in essence I'm getting it for free
yeah and then I've got all the capital
appreciation from all these other
properties so buying my own
just doesn't make any sense whatsoever
because if I bought my own house only
buying a crappy house like this though
what's a 4.6 million crappy oh yeah is a
very nice house but crappy for a for an
investment book yeah yeah yeah it's like
it's a crappy investment
yeah it just is a it's just a terrible
investment yeah so let's do the figures
on yours
how much is your apartment worth I don't
know I've not looked I think it's better
450,000 where it is not looked should we
look it up look it up let's do it you
know gonna prove to you now why now in
all fairness this doesn't work anywhere
near as well the cheaper the property if
you buy a lot if you want to live in a
house as they were over a hundred
thousand pound is it's a little bit
different but so I'm gonna need to get
you the course called yeah what's
supposed to go hold on do you look it up
look it up look it up I've gotta find a
contract so while we're doing that just
wait a minute let me just find the
contract alright we've just found
Alistair's house Zoopla estimate is
seven hundred and fifty seven grand okay
so if you bought that how much money we
just put down seven five seven roughly
140 but let me get you the exact figure
seven five seven zero zero times not
point two five hundred and hundred neat
and a thousandth of 190 okay 119
thousand you have to put down mm-hm and
what was your mum for you and what your
mortgage outstanding bit seven five
minus one ninety one ninety five six
seven five six seven times not fun not
for approximately eighteen hundred and
ninety pound a month which
coincidentally this is funny isn't it
it's so funny about your rent 520 pounds
20 pounds off limits is the same right
serious situation where the interest
only is the same as your rent right so
it means you one hundred ninety thousand
pound it's just wasted whereas instead
you could invest that being twenty
percent interest on it which more than
cover your rent had you supposed to show
you that it's a crap investment isn't it
it's a terrible investment and I know
I've now got the the landlord's details
as
pause to the agents and so yeah he I
know it's more see how much money's
worth on Ziploc so I'm just that I just
I knew it was sold for that about eight
years ago it's gonna be like something
pretty more wasn't it less interest in
that we obviously I get reply we rain um
because I don't wanna put hundred and
ninety grand into our flat but just do
the maths it just doesn't make sense to
buy your own it's just idiotic yeah so
there you go so you are missing
something yes I think yeah I think you
should as a savvy investor you should
use that money better and invest it
wisely if you really wanted to omit if
you really want you to invest your money
wisely
you just know you mean technically you
could buy a house that was like a HM own
living one of the rooms or something
yeah okay cool but if you want to live
in a half-decent house yeah
rent it and it gives you more
flexibility as well yes a lot uh like I
didn't know we were gonna move to London
and so I moved house and then six months
later I was just like sorry landlord I'm
moving to London and moved to London and
if I don't like it here in beckons field
I might go I wanna move to Richmond yeah
I've got that flexibility you know my do
that my mortgage from Aynsley know it's
a right pain in the ass mmm because you
because you because you're I don't want
to commit myself to somewhere when I
might want to move around or try
different house I've lived in a lot i've
lived in old farmhouses lived in new
built i've tried different stuff it's
just to me it's just a no brainer we
should we should have a fricken episode
about this why maybe we should do an
episode about this maybe no more the
question has raised the new episode
thoughts will thank you but on that
bombshell that is time to end so we'll
see you next Saturday at 7 p.m. don't
forget to check us out on YouTube
Spotify apple itunes deezer stitcher
there's more there's Lourdes enough I
don't know where we're at but we're all
over the place probably many questions
we'll try out some on the show and we'll
see you next Saturday at 7 p.m.
see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]